thank you
do you hear me now yes
all right i think i think i got it
am i am i uh audible now
yes thank you okay
call the house finance committee meeting
to order
as chair of the house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coveted
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
and hybrid this is a public hearing on
bills referred to the committee and
scheduled on the house calendar for
today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for member of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i am
confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600 or email
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law clerk will call the roll
can you hear me hold the blue button
all right
representative ober i'm here in hudson
i'm alone in the house at the moment
russ is out jogging i don't know what
yeah all right representative hamburger
yes i'm in my home in kearsarge uh i'm
alone in the room
um
thing
the last voice i heard was karen's
saying
we couldn't hear anything and i agree
with karen
yeah i think we're showing why remote
meetings don't work very well
perfectly
uh
i think everybody's here except the
hey hey mickey landogran would you speak
up because
uh i think you may be the only other
person in the uh
lob and maybe the lob is the problem
yeah i i'm sure you can hear me i'm
actually over in our office at the state
house right now i'm trying to
coordinate with any technical help over
in the lob
i think there was a uh an account set up
that the audio was picking up on and it
logged off and i'm trying to pull it
back in now
uh representative emmerich so there we
go
uh hamrick is in his home office in
hampton
okay representative earth president
hello in my home office
representative edwards uh president i'm
in my home office in auburn with the
office door shot
all right representative yes president
i'm in my
office uh home office in windham uh my
i'm at my house in um concord and i am
alone
representative norgren um i'm in my
house in hanover
and i'm alone in the dining room
representative yes i'm present in my
home in conway and no one else is in the
room
leishman
representative is filling in senator
okay
probably in rochester very good
representative hatch
i'm here in the finance room
arizona rogers
i'm here at my house in concord with my
dog romeo
we're far out there representative
i am here in my home my husband is
elsewhere in the house i'm alone in this
room
thank you representative heath good
morning
representative murray kate murray is
here in newcastle with the dog hershey
and my husband is in
is downstairs and representative
coming here in the committee room all
right
we have unanimous attendance
mr chair your audio is way down we can
just barely hear you
i don't think these are working ten
all right you hear me now yes sir yes
thank you
thank you for pointing it out all right
uh
first item on the agenda for 10 o'clock
is
senate bill 77 fn
that's that would uh be a subject matter
in division one i'll call upon
chairman of division one representative
to make a motion or mr chairman we're
not an exec we're in a public hearing
all right public thank you very much
happy to take a make a motion but i
think we need to have the public hearing
first
all right i do not have a list of any
member of the public
does the uh to the people controlling
this
from lba do you have the list yeah uh
we've got senator uh
d'alessandro senator lou d'alessandro
here is the prime sponsor to introduce
the bill
very good senator d'alessandro you're
recognized
thank you mr chairman and distinguished
members of the committee
uh thank you for giving me this
opportunity first we gotta unmute him
he's unmuted can you hear me yes
okay uh thank you for allowing me to
come before you to testify for senate
bill 77
i sponsored the same bill last year
which passed the senate by voice vote
yes all right start at the beginning i
saw you moving but all right you ready
i'm ready now thank you okay my pleasure
sir thank you kitty
uh i sponsored this bill this very same
bill last year
uh which passed the senate by voice vote
the sheriff's association requested me
to sponsor this bill
their fees for service have not been
increased for more than 10 years
they're asking for a moderate increase
to cover their on their own
increases in the cost of fuel wages
mailing
the cost of cruises and every other
aspect of writ
services the sheriff's uh will be here
to testify on it and got a favorable
vote
in the senate and i'm hoping you will
support the bill now i understand
representative ober
has an amendment to offer and i'm i'm
fine with the
uh i'm fine with the amendment uh i
i hope she's run up by the sheriffs uh
and they're fighting with it also but
again
thanks for your time and i would
appreciate your support on this piece of
legislation
if you have any questions i'd be happy
to address them
many questions for the senator i see a
hand raised by representative ober
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
say that yes
the senator has seen the amendment and
the
amendment has been seen by two county
sheriffs and got
a favorable approval rating
thank you any further questions from the
committee
okay any question any further mickey is
there anybody else
thank you very much thank you very much
mr chuba that uh
have a great american day thank you
senator
we do have two additional folks signed
up to testify first is uh sheriff
dominic ricciardi
and he is pulled in and able to speak
followed by marissa chase and i will
bring her in once the sheriff is
completed
all right sheriff you're recognized to
speak to the finance committee
good morning chairman wyler and members
of the committee
my name is dominic ricciardi i'm the
carroll county sheriff
and president of the new hampshire
sheriff's association
i'm here to testify in favor of senate
bill
77 finance all to do
relative to the fees and services of the
sheriff's and deputy sheriffs
we're asking for a minor increase of
service fees
these fees have not been increased
since about 2010 inflation obviously has
raised the cost of fuel wages
mailings cost of cruises every other
aspect to the writ of services
costs have all been absorbed by the
taxpayers in each county
and as sheriffs responsible for these
services
we feel it's time to increase the fees
so that the share of some
of the costs with the actual entities
that are using the services
the average increase is about five
dollars per service
um the postage increase will reflect a
more accurate cost
to mail some of the packets we receive
this will offset
costs from the taxpayers to the person
requesting the service
there is a mechanism in place for people
who need this service
to seek an exception upon motion to the
court
to have the fees waived we feel the
proposed increase
are modest and we ask that you find this
ought to pass
and thank you for your consideration if
you have any questions i'd
be welcome to answer any questions for
the sheriff and
i have a question for you sheriff did
you get a look at the
amendment i personally have not
what what the amendment i believe does
and you'll hear about it shortly if you
stay on
is to put the the funding
into the counties to make the decision
on how much to pay the sheriff
so it would be part of the direct part
of the county budget which more or less
it is now but
the increase would be allowed by the
county delegation so
that's more or less i believe what the
amendment will say and
we'll be coming to that later on we have
another person
waiting any any questions for the
seeing none thank you sheriff if you
want to stay on
you'll be able to hear the amendment
thank you and
i have marissa chase here and i'll just
remind if anyone else is in the
attendees wishing to testify
to raise your virtual hand um that's all
we have signed up ahead of time is
marissa is our final
testifier thank you
all right miss chase welcome to finance
committee
thank you representative and thank you
mickey it's good to see you
for the record my name is marissa chase
i'm the executive director for the new
hampshire association for justice
which is a statewide professional
association of trial attorneys
um and we thank senator d'alessandro for
prime sponsoring this bill and for the
sheriff's association for working with
us when this bill was introduced by
senator d'alessandro last year
we had requested an amendment that went
through unanimously
that just simply codified what most
sheriffs do in practice anyway
which is if a sheriff is serving papers
at the same location
the same address but multiple people are
at
that same address that are all being
served that the sheriff only charged
mileage for that scenario once
which is again widespread practice
anyway we heard from some of our members
you know our attorneys are typically the
ones that
um utilize um this
system for having sheriffs serve papers
so this was our request and again we
thank the sheriffs for
and senator d'alessandro for um being
amenable to that
be happy to do my best to answer any
questions you may have and thank you all
again
thank you miss chase has anyone have any
seeing none are there any further
people with their hands up mickey i see
no more uh folks wishing to testify on
this bill
thank you mr chairman but do you not
have to open the exact session
well that's true is is it your plan to
exec because it would be i would be
amenable to making a motion
well i think it's also proper to
introduce the amendment during the
public hearing so that
people that there can be familiar with
it and
mickey if you are able to put it on the
screen or
have a presentation so everybody can
look at it i actually don't have the
amendment representative weiler i can
try to track it down or if uh
hoffman has the amendment mickey okay i
can
it's in the lba folder i don't know what
that means
okay i have it as well mickey i can
screen share
okay
so this amendment keeps everything in
central del alesandro's
bill the exact same however it adds
lines five through 10 which gives the
county delegations and the town county
delegations are the ones who control the
budgets in the county working with the
county commissioners
the right to vote once annually to
increase the fees by the consumer price
index
for the northeast region as published
by the bureau of labor statistics the
previous
june and that's all it does
um it has been seen in by two counties
sheriffs in two counties and they were
in favor of it as was
okay if you'd uh page down a little bit
so that clerk can read the
amendment number it's up at the top
yep there we go 12
12.
okay any questions from the committee
on the amendment i see uh i see your
uh representative irf has his hand up
representative earth you're recognized
thank you mr chairman when i read line
one and maybe
i just misunderstand how this was worded
but it says amend the bill by replacing
all after enacting clause with the
following
yes that's a new paragraph at the bottom
of the bill where the effective date was
that's why line 11 appears effective
date again
and line 11 was modified to say it will
take effect
60 days after passage because the
feedback from the sheriff's
and the two counties checked was that
they could not
take effect immediately they had to
okay so it's not replacing the entire
bill no stating a new paragraph
keith line three new paragraph at the
bottom
and the paragraph is 12 line
five okay
i guess we might have to change that
amend the bill by replacing all after
the enacting clause which would take out
including the mileage amendment that was
previously added
about if you got multiple people at the
same address you only charge mileage
once
and uh i can see removing some of the
other
fee language but that we probably want
anything further
all right so representative
representative weiler i have a question
mary heath
all right representative heath for a
question thank you mr chair
my question is um with regard to
um we had a statement from marissa chase
and also the the sheriff's
but this bill if enacted and passed
would delay the whole process out at
least another year
is is am i understanding that correctly
by shifting the authority to the
counties
we're delaying the process because when
that we're in that
budget cycle right now and this bill
would not be passed
uh within that time frame so could
someone just re
uh respond to my comments please
okay uh representative ober did you
understand the question
well mr chairman have we mailed hard
copies of the bills to people so they
can look at them
because as far as i know you can only
i believe everybody here has has gotten
an email copy of 77 as it was introduced
or the trouble is you can only look at
one thing on your screen
at a time and did they get hard copies
so they can look at them
no anybody not have a hard copy that
we have some on the table for the people
in the room
i can see both on my screen together
all right sheriff ricciardi had a
question
thank you um my question would be
if i understand this right the amendment
would put the
cost back onto the county yeah as far as
raising the
um like the last representative said
as far as raising the funds in the
county's budget
are you saying that the county doesn't
but this money is reimbursed by the
state
okay this is this is a rsa but
state so yes the county does raise money
it would have been going into effect
july 2021
so now it is correct that now you're
putting it off not just 60 days but
unless the county have an emergency
meeting to
redo the budget you're putting it off
thank you further comments
from the sheriff's uh
yeah yes thank you mr i guess i want to
make sure that i'm not
confused about something are are am i to
understand that if we
if we pass the bill and pass this
amendment
that what we would be doing is approving
the fee increases for
now so to speak and then saying that
going
forward in future years the the
increases could happen
sort of on a regular basis so to speak
if the if the uh
if the county convention approved it but
but
that that for this year the fees that we
approve in the
in the unamended portion of the bill
would be
i believe you're correct uh
representative lin does anybody
mr hawk i mean mr kane because
this amendment was done by nancy lavines
who unfortunately
is not on the call and she was
instructed that the intention of the
bill was to add
the ability of the counties to do that
leave the existing
fees alone leave the existing mileage
alone
and to change the effective date however
without the appropriate
lba people on the call i'm not sure why
mickey's here without having talked to
her but he obviously hadn't even
seen the amendment i don't know what to
say but i did email mr kane
to clarify that mrs lavinas had not made
an egregious error here but i don't know
well at this time the the um
amendment causes confusion by having
replacing all after the enacting clause
which i don't think is the intent
so we we may have to withdraw the
maybe for another day and and passed
if we pass the bill as it's as it's
written then it could
it could uh we need to have mr kane
chime in on this because
my county is not willing to have the
bill passed as amended
hillsborough county has a as
representative heath knows
has a serious problem in that we are the
only county
with two different superior courts
with our sheriffs going in two different
ways
all the time pulled by court
requirements
plus adding this on so my county is not
in favor of the bill as drafted by
senator del alesandro
and in fact hadn't even been asked about
it they're not opposed to it
but without this language they are not
in favor of having this at all
because it doesn't it doesn't give them
enough relief this is the first time in
11 years
these fees have been changed and they're
being moved by five dollars
i saw i saw that i see the name hoffman
i see
representative lin still had his hand up
did you want to say something further
represent lynn
no i'm sorry i just forgot to lower my
hand but i've done that now sorry about
that
thank you representative walner for it
well she had her hand up and then she
left all right
mike hoffman have you thank you mr chair
i wasn't involved in drafting this but i
can
get something to or less quickly if the
yes we don't want the language that says
amend the bill by replacing all after
the enacting clause it should say
number 10 i get or what's the last
paragraph
paragraph 9a i think so it should it
should probably be
10 or no it should be 12.
although i look down here and it says
all after paragraph am i
seeing the whole bill here i think so
so if i understand this is a replace all
and that was not the intent
we want to add this to the end of the
existing bill
yes that was not the intent i have a
series of email exchanges with nancy
about this and she says it only adds to
it so i don't know what is going on
because i questioned her and then she
said she wasn't available this morning
so i can look at my email but it doesn't
help not having it
here the idea was to leave the the bill
as it was
and to add the ability for the counties
once a year to also raise the wages
or the fees because as i said
hillsborough county has a horrible time
with those two
superior court houses when only when
every other county only has to deal with
one of them
so i don't know and i i know nancy
wasn't available today but
the other confusion is that um
the bill the last roman numeral on the
bill is
is roman 9 and this is roman 12
so what happened to romans 10 and 11. i
believe that
the amendment should be uh number 10
roman 10 rather than roman 12
and we don't want to amend we want to
amend the bill by replacing all after
roman nine b
so if uh if
we can table this discussion for now
and come back to it later in this in
this meeting
then uh that will work out i think if
mike hoffman can probably
make those changes and bring us a new
amendment is everyone okay with that
well ken we're in public section right
now couldn't we just terminate the
public hearing on sb 77
no i'm gonna uh i'm gonna but we're not
in an exact session
right so we don't have to table it
because we're in a public hearing we
okay but i wanted i want to recess the
public hearing so i could introduce
the amendment in the public hearing
which is the proper way to do it
that's different from tabling now i
agree with that yes
all right we'll recess this discussion
on
uh on senate bill 77 until we see the
new amendment
all right and mike hoffman said he's
going to he's going to fix those
problems
we have senate bill we have senate bill
at 10 25 so we're coming to that a
little bit late
and that was uh in division two
and i'll call upon representative
we're still in a public hearing for
senate ability to represent weiler
we we need to have the public hearing
first okay
this this will be a public hearing on
senate bill 82.
um and i have one person signed up to
speak and that's the prime sponsor uh
senator birdsall and she is on the call
and is able to be recognized
very good all right senator birdsall is
right
thank you mr chair and thank you
committee um for hearing senate bill
82 this was i am the prime sponsor for
which encompasses the towns of derry
hampstead in windham
and uh senate bill 82 was actually
uh holdover from last year it had
passed the senate passed the house
it got caught up in the omnibus bill and
assembly i would say the wrong amendment
got attached
so what senate bill 82 does
is correct what the amendment um
what the omnibus bill did last year
basically um this is a result
the bill makes whole to those school
districts who went from
part-time kindergarten to full-time and
it includes the appropriation for fiscal
year 2020 and fiscal year 2021.
apparently what happened when we when
the um
omnibus bill was put together they they
authorized the um they
authorized the um
process but they didn't make the
appropriations so
for instance when dairy went to go to
the
department of education for their
appropriation the
department of education couldn't
appropriate it because it wasn't
authorized
so senate bill 82 is to correct that um
that issue and with that i will
um terminate my comments and try and
answer any questions i
i believe that the department ed may be
here as well to
kind of go through it as well thank you
senator
question from representative heath thank
you mr chair my question
for the senator is
this bill will this bill
include all the towns
that have um adopted full day
kindergarten
in the event or are there other towns
that have not yet
adopted full-time kindergartens so would
they
be included in this process if this bill
were to pass
yes any any of the towns and i i'm sorry
i'm having
troubles uh scrolling on my
um but um it should encompass
all of the towns that went from
part-time to full-time and i think
that's
includes chester epsom dairy
salem and um there are i think a total
and if you look if you look at the bill
and the
fiscal note i believe it lists all those
schools
thank you senator can i if i may mr
chair
follow-up question um senator do you
know if there are other towns that have
not yet
adopted full-day kindergarten at that i
do not know that's probably a question
that
um maybe the department of ed can answer
hey thank you senator
and also this is this is out of the 2021
budget not out of the future budget but
the
past budget so we'll discuss with the
department of ed whether they have the
appropriate money or not
when we get a chance to bring them on
board
okay thank you regina thank you
all right um so i would ask that if
anyone in the attendees would like to
testify please raise their virtual hand
i do have one hand raised uh john
pascarelli i'll bring him
in i'll also answer representative
heath's question there
as of this time there are no other full
day programs known besides what's in the
fiscal note
however this bill would provide funding
for them in perpetuity should any come
on board
if you'd like to hear from the
department on that or if you have any
other questions they are here too i can
pull them in
mr chair just let me know i guess it's
next
so i do have john pascarelli here a
member of the public i believe who is
looking to testify and i do have mark
manganiello from the department of
education to answer any questions mark
manganiello with the department of
education
all right uh mr man jenny mangeniello
did i get that right close
um would
is this money in the budget that you
have presently for this
present fiscal year yep um
thank you for the question chair uh
division two put senate bill
82 into the budget so it is currently in
house bill 2
which includes the language from senate
bill 82 the and the appropriation
i did some research this morning looking
at schools that potentially are moving
to a full day kindergarten for
state fiscal year 22 and currently no
pro
no schools at the moment are moving to
full day kindergarten so the
appropriations you have in the budget at
this moment
are appropriate and should be enough to
cover any future expenses
as we know them at the moment thank you
anything further to add
hi everybody how's everybody doing today
good
can you hear me okay yes
um i'm kind of off topic with you
folks's discussion
um what i would like
to do is talk about broadband i mean
this
is also a meeting about broadband
correct
not yet uh i've got them i've got them
all on a schedule
and the broadband is uh
scheduled for senate bill 85
um 10 50. so we're a little we're a
little early on that yet
at 10 50 if you if you stay
around and listen when i get to what
senate bill 85 that
that will be the next bill after after
we complete the work on this one
so um this is all about the kindergarten
funding
so we'll we'll welcome your comments
when i
begin the hearing on senate bill 85.
thank you sir
okay anything further on senate bill 82
i believe that uh representative umberg
has taken care of it and if
there's no further comments so no
further people uh waiting to comment
mickey is there anybody else with a hand
up in the representative
representative heath has a question i
believe okay representative heath
thank you representative weiler i just i
just want to um
ascertain that if in the event
that future schools come on board
with full day kindergarten then in fact
this current situation that we put in
the
budget in division two will
in fact be a reality for those new
towns
um mickey can you answer that i believe
there was previous
testimony to that effect i i can't
answer that but i'll let mark answer it
okay
just to confirm representative there is
a
there's appropriation authority it says
they're on after and there's warrant
authority to continue the funding
um if other communities do end up
joining full day kindergarten
thank you very much i just wanted to
make sure
okay further comments or questions
on senate bill 82
seeing none well um
we'll go into exec session on senate
bill 82
since we've had all the testimony and
everybody has seen
the uh the printed copy of it
i'll entertain a motion from
representative umberger in the executive
session
uh thank you and um i would like to say
that when senator birdsall
brought this over to us we certainly
felt
that there were sufficient dollars
available
and actually the vote from the committee
on the funding of these projects
was seven to zero so we
we had unanimous agreement
on funding this program
so the the schools the kindergartens
that were affected
are chester salem
windham brookline dairy and
epson so if i could
i will turn it over to representative
lin
to make the motion
uh thank you madam chair yes um mr chair
i would make
since the money is already included in
the in the budget i would make a motion
that this bill is
uh should be uh itl
expedient to legislate second
okay a motion from representative lynn
for an expedient a second
from representative petry further
discussion
this was an ito the motion is
inexpedient to legislate
further discussion i see representative
heath has her hand up
now my question is this thank you mr
chair um
and we end up with a continuing
resolution
would that mean that those kindergarten
programs would not get this funding
well it would also mean that we wouldn't
pass the budget if
those two things happened uh obviously
we if we itl this and the budget does
not pass
then it could be delayed it's unlikely
that everything in the budget will be
removed but some things will be removed
and
you know i believe that the finance
committee will be aware that of the
effect if
if this were removed so so mr chair
would it be better to retain the bill um
until we know that the budget passed i i
completely agreed with the itl because
we did put it in the budget
but my my concern right now is in the
event that the budget doesn't pass
we're going to leave all these towns
without that funding
and i'm just very concerned about that
especially right now
should we wait all right so if we do
retain the bill
it won't provide them the uh the funding
until next year likely because we'd have
to
retain the bill and reintroduce it for
next year but
at least there would be a chance that it
would be passed possibly in january by
the house
so yeah that that's that's a scenario
if we if we tabled it we would have to
have it out by the deadline
it and and we wouldn't know at the
deadline whether or not
whether or not it had the budget had
passed so tabling would wouldn't
do much um okay
yes uh if i could ask a question of uh
mr landergen please
go ahead yes uh mickey
if we retain this bill
we should in fact recommend that the
funding go
away from the budget because
we have put it in because we
felt that it was the right thing to do
but if we are now going to decide to
retain it
then that means the funding should not
if it's the intent of the committee to
support these payments to these
districts
the fact you've passed in house bill 2
would provide that
that level of funding those
appropriation dollars if you wanted to
retain
senate bill 82 as a
as a backup plan in case something does
happen to house bill 2
um you wouldn't need to alter the
funding in house bill 2 in any way
okay thank you i just feel that um
in in certainly in my mind there is no
question
that this will be included in the
you know the budget doesn't pass
there'll be
lots of things that
that aren't there and so i would
um i would certainly recommend that we
itl it knowing full well when we
come to a committee of conference that
um
this will be um you know one thing that
we will
insist upon and because it
is catching us up from errors that were
made by the last legislature
in 20 and 21. so i
i think that itl
is the right way to go
thank you representative um
walnut has her hand up thank you
um i guess historically i think what
we've done
is we when we have put things like this
in the budget
we have then retained the bill
just in case there is the chance that
the budget didn't pass or
the particular item was removed from the
budget
no agreement could be made i mean i
agree that this one i think
is pretty safe in the budget but i do
think it's
it's kind of a back-up plan and then we
come back
in what we've done in the past is these
retain bills
we've come back in um the fall
and um if the budget's passed and if
they're there
we then have uh moved in expedience it
seems like
we've stepped we've sort of skipped a
step
um so just
if it i guess if it was any if there was
any chance that it wouldn't
be included in the budget and we don't
really know that for
for sure right now um i would
go for retain and then come back in the
fall
and do inexpedient if
thank you representative ober as your
candidate
thank you mr chairman the former chair
of finance is correct that there have
been
times when we have
retained bills in fact i have
represented buco's bill
retained on water because i was not
certain that this year i could put it in
and i knew it was a bill that should
have been filed in the second year of
the biennium not the first year with the
budget
but in two previous occasions when we
knew we were going to put representative
buco's
bill in the budget which we
affectionately called the bucco bucks
we did go ahead and itl the bill right
away
and the blurb said that it was itl
because
the money was going to be in the budget
so we have done
both things i am in supportive of the
motion
of division two thank you mr chairman
thank you representative walner
sorry i forgot to lower it okay
so the situation before us as we exact
this bill
is we have a motion and a second for
inexpedient
either the motion remains and that's the
one we vote on
or it's withdrawn and if i don't see it
an opportunity i don't see the hand up
for
the person making the making the motion
so the
motion before us that we are voting on
is inexpedient
the clerk will call a roll on that
motion
thank you mr motion is inexpedient if
you're in favor you'll say
i or yes or if you're opposed you make
thank you mr chairman uh representative
ober
yes representative umberger
yes representative ranjullo for
danielson
[Music]
representative burrish yeah president
petrie votes yes
representative emrick yes representative
earth
yes representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean
yes representative lynn yes
representative walder no
representative nogrin no representative
cucco
no representative leishman
representative hatch
representative rogers no
representative walsh no
president heath no
representative murray no representative
weiler
yes mr chairman of voters 12-9 in favor
of the motion
the motion of any expedient is uh in
expedience the legislate is adopted and
we will not put this on the consent
calendar thank you
all right now we're ready for
senate bill 85 and it is the proper time
um we'll call upon
uh it's a division one bill we'll call
call upon representative ober
for a motion it's a public hearing mr
chairman uh yes this thank you
i'm moving ahead too fast all right this
will i'm open a public hearing
on senate bill 85. uh
who do we have ready to introduce the
bill mickey
i believe we have senator bradley here
he's the prime sponsor to introduce it
we also have senator khan uh chris
norwood and maura weston
to testify if anyone else beyond that is
wishing to to testify i would just ask
you raise your virtual hand
uh and i am going to allow uh andrea and
jonah
to take over the hosting duties here so
um
please defer to them they'll they'll
assist with calling on
folks to testify thank you all right
we'll call upon senator bradley to
introduce the bill
good morning mr chairman and members of
the finance committee
i hope everybody's doing well this
morning
i'm pleased to be here um and supporting
senate bill 85
i want to take this opportunity to
thank the broad range of sponsors of
this bill
including representative umberger on
your committee
if the pandemic has shown us anything
it is that our state excuse me needs to
enhance
broadband access in many areas of the
state
that are underserved or unserved by
broadband providers
whether it's for telemedicine education
purposes
telecommuting staying in touch with
family and friends
the value of your home
broadband is absolutely an essential
commodity
in this day and age when broadband
began to be established obviously
throughout our state
it's done in a very different model than
telephone service was in the past or
electric
service was in the past where um
universal service was socialized through
regulated rates and the entire
um spectrum of regulation
broadband has been different i would
argue
that because of its difference we have
had a much more
innovative and much more cost effective
and technology
forward-thinking application of the
installation of broadband
but because of um you know the
difficulty in some instances of bringing
it
to more rural areas of the state there
are
pockets of new hampshire that do not
have broadband
so given that
there has been an influx of potential
federal money i thought it was important
to
introduce senate bill 85 to create a
matching grant
program that would utilize this federal
money
matched by either provider dollars or
local efforts whether it be counties
municipalities or communication
districts to facilitate the
um construction of better broadband
access
clause it calls on the office of
strategic initiatives
and i know the representative over has
an amendment that i support
to if the
governor's proposal on the department of
energy moves forward which you folks
um have i think wisely included in your
budget
and it's my hope the senate will too but
that
um representative ober's amendment would
put the department of energy in charge
appropriately so of managing the grants
there is rule making provided
the let me just touch briefly on the
way the bill has devised the percentages
given that there has been a influx or
will be an influx of federal dollars
i thought it was appropriate that it be
a 50 50 match
that could be either state funds or
state funds
using federal funds for the 50
match and then um a process
where providers or as i said before
municipalities counties or communication
districts
would provide the other 50
of the funding that's um
basically how it works i think the need
is there
there were a couple of amendments that
the senate
added to it and one more amendment that
myself and senator khan
will propose for your consideration
the planning process for access to these
funds
there is a whole process that goes into
place
before wires can be strung
knowing which households need service is
an integral part of of that and there
are costs involved with planning
and then um there was in the initial
version
of the bill a clause that said
the upload speed should be uh 25
and the download speed three the senate
amendment
to language that said promotes a faster
service up and including to a gigabyte
of service
um let me just touch mr chairman on the
amendment
the amendment makes it clear that
any um construction that was
um undertaken as of january uh
one of this year shall be eligible for
funding
um some of us have heard that some towns
are
holding off on planning or proceeding
hoping to get this grant funding this
makes sure that they can move forward
while knowing that the grants will be
there so
happy to answer any questions and thank
you very much thank you senator
we have a question from representative
edwards
uh thank you mr chair and i i have two
questions that are related for senator
bradley
uh uh if i may the the first one is
um i i understand the appeal
of uh of having faster uh connectivity
than the uh the minimum set by the
federal government
with the 25 and the three going up to a
gig
instead i get it um but when we do that
don't we uh lose the matching
part of this and and we have created
effectively
our own program where we have to go it
alone because
their standards are so much lower than
ours i do not believe that that's the
case
um i mean i i could be
corrected if i'm wrong but we never
heard representative that kind of
testimony
from any of the experts um from any of
the cable providers
um or any of the public if that's the
case then
we might have to make a change but i
don't believe it is ask that question
of some of the folks that will follow me
though
yes sir thank you very much i i i do
think it's a concern we're looking at
the the broadband issue in auburn so
i've i've read the language and
it just is a concern of mine sort of the
the the other
is um we the current law that we've set
this up on i understand
has the municipality or the
communications network
issue a bond and then that bond gets
paid back
uh over 20 years would this matching
fund with the state monies
also be paid back over 20 years because
of the municipal bond
um so the way that this is structured to
work representative is that it'd be a 50
50 cost share so the state obviously
would take the lead but using especially
right now is there is going to be
a lot of federal funding for 50 of the
cost
i have felt that there should be
participation
by whether it's a town a county or the
providers
to move forward with you know getting
this kind of a grant
there is a bonding provision that
municipalities
can go forward with bonding that
was part of senator khan's bill senate
bill 170
that was passed i don't know three or
four years ago probably
i don't think that would affect how a
municipality
chose to finance if they chose to
finance it
through a bond hopefully with the you
know
kind of dollars that we're talking about
those kind of municipal bondings can
would not be favored but it my
understanding is it would remain an
option thank you senator i i
i support the initiative i i'm just
curious about the details thank you for
your time yeah you're welcome thank you
senator representative ober for a
question thank you mr chairman
good morning senator bradley good
morning
uh thank you for working with me on the
amendment we have to ensure that
even if osi goes away in the budget that
we can continue this program
i think i heard you say and i got
something from your assistant not too
long ago we'd already started this
meeting about
a an amendment that senator khan had
in the house we only have one amendment
per bill i don't know how the senate
does it
so i'm a little concerned about
whether with the amendment i have
because i didn't know anything about
senator khan's amendment until your
assistant sent it to me this morning
how we would proceed with this bill
so um representative ober i think if you
look at page two of the bill
um on line three
establishment of a challenge process
so senator khan and i are proposing and
you can fold this into your amendment
representative ober would be fine
that would it would just say projects in
in the in planning designer terms
negotiations
and not under construction as of january
1 2021
shall be eligible for funding so it's it
really is nothing more than
um allowing um
a process that had already started that
had not started construction
because some towns are waiting to be
eligible for the bonds and that would go
um at the end of line six on page
two okay my second question if you would
take a second question
yep we are we've
been working and i know you and
chairman weiler and i and others have
been working with the governor
about the ara funds which we hope
to have in state at some point time and
i
think this would be part of that funding
yet i believe that part of the guidance
we've gotten
in the bill although we haven't gotten
guidance per se
written guidance other than what was in
the bill
revolved around the fact that you could
not use that money
to replace existing spending
will this impact that and if it does
how would it impact it would we be
replacing existing
spending of some sort so
my understanding representative is this
would all be new
spending um similar to
you know what the gopher committee and
the governor proposed last summer
that unfortunately because of the time
the very
very tight timelines uh very little of
the money could be
uh used this would be
it would not be replacing of existing
spending but it would be
this would be new spending on
infrastructure and as you know
um in the legislation the past congress
um infrastructure spending like water
roads and
and broadband was highlighted as a
allowable use certainly that was my
understanding
of how that federal legislation works
any further questions for senator
bradley
seeing none andrea who's the next
uh thank you chairman weiler and
members of the house
finance committee i am senator jay kahn
i represent 15 of 23 towns in cheshire
county
and thank you for hearing senate bill
85. i want to compliment my colleague
senator bradley from the outset
he has been attentive to the testimony
that's been received
led the way for a 24 to nothing vote on
this
in the senate uh and i'm pleased to be
here to
to speak on its behalf um
since senate bill 170 was passed in 2018
there have been seven projects completed
in
the state with municipal funding it's a
real stretch on communities
to do this seven have used exclusively
the bonding uh
authority and uh i believe it was five
other projects
uh uh worked their way through
uh the latest uh round of
cares money that was allocated by the
governor
to towns or providers
to improve services at least
to the minimum standards established by
the fcc
um so we
uh now come to uh the implementation
of uh senate bill 85 hopefully uh
and as we look forward to that uh we've
got
quite a lineup of projects that
hit the queue this last winter and
spring
since january 1st of 2021
with warrant articles going before towns
some of which have been passed
some of which are still pending so there
are uh as of uh current
at least 15 projects that i'm aware of
that are in the queue nine of those the
warrant articles have
already been adopted by towns
uh and then the other six are still in
process
um and of those nine
projects they are in four different
counties
so it's not like it's just localized in
uh
uh towns in cheshire county though uh
there are many
uh in in my district that have either
used it or
planned to use it in the in the future
i mean these are spread into merrimack
and
and hillsborough and sullivan counties
as well
uh and i know senator bradley is working
uh in in his
areas of the state that uh are
interested
in uh taking advantage of a broadband
match project
uh fund and its availability uh
so where we are currently is that these
projects are not
following through uh to uh
to signing of contracts and bonding
uh because they really do want to be
eligible for
the matching grants it can make a huge
difference
many of these towns in my area that i'm
aware of
uh there's like 700 people uh in the
towns
so uh they are not have a
great investments for a provider
necessarily
they cover wide areas but small
service populations this is why the
matching grant
becomes so important if we are going to
really try to lead the way
and make sure that households are not
left behind
and we've all heard the stories about
the households left behind
the towns are really looking at their
survival
uh because if if somebody
can't uh uh connect to the internet
uh it's just a a stopper as far as
uh people uh want it's it's depressing
home values property values
uh keeping people from starting
businesses
in uh smaller towns and communities
around the state so
in order to level the playing field uh
this this grant program is really
important and i
uh to to representative ober's uh
question i'm sure that we can take this
one-line
amendment that senator bradley and i
have worked on
uh that would make projects eligible uh
if they uh are in the planning stage and
not yet under construction as of january
1st
of 2021 uh and incorporate that in any
amendment
uh that uh the representative would
bring
forward and i'd be glad to to work with
you and senator bradley to
to pass those words over to you and and
and help
make that uh possible uh mr chairman i
i will uh cease on my testimony and
uh be glad to take any questions
thank you senator kahn senator
representative ober has a question
thank you mr chairman and senator khan
thank you for your words as you know
senator bradley said i had an amendment
that he had already approved
have you started working on a joint
amendment that uses both of those
languages
because we were intending to work on
this bill this morning and this
is totally unknown to me until
senator bradley's secretary was kind
enough to
email me a copy but we'd already started
here so have you taken the first steps
to make that joint amendment
i have not and i was unaware of
your amendment but um if you can allow
us
a day here i i'm sure that we would
further representative ober
i guess i would like to know if the
senate can then
amend this bill on their side on a bill
that they have
because i think we're ready to move
forward this morning
and this was unknown but i believe the
senate still has
bills that they could use to to make
this amendment happy
can that be done senator khan so you
guys can work on this since
nothing's been done on a joint amendment
at this point
um i
[Music]
know that they are here on the
on the senate side i'm not i don't serve
on
uh election law and municipal
affairs i i would guess it would
most likely be on a bill there but i i
don't know what's left on their docket
anything further represented over no i'm
just going to check and see if jeb might
still be online
okay representative edwards for a
question
thank you mr chair uh good talking to
you again senator khan
i i i i assume you heard the uh the two
questions i
asked senator bradley i i'll just focus
on the first one which is
given that the federal standard is a
25 download and three upload
and we're at a gig if the town
applies for this and they're say at a
upload and download or vice versa rather
do do they qualify still for the federal
grant or
or are we really no longer matching
we're we're taking over the program
because
they exceed the federal standard do you
know
sir yep yeah i i guess i'd i'd uh i'll
take that question representative
uh and and offer two perspectives one
is a town currently can can set
a in their rfp a standard that's above
the fcc minimum
they can't bar anybody from applying
but they can set a higher criteria
so if if a proposal is 25 by 3
from an existing provider then then
that's an eligible uh response to be
considered by a town
but a town can uh elect to not
uh accept any rfp
uh that is below the standard that they
set
in the rfp so a town could set a higher
standard
that it wishes to have for those
unserved areas
rsa-333 describes the rfp
process so that that number one number
two
i think i think you could uh and i think
the senate bill 85 allows
for a standard to be
set for the grant funding that
could exceed the the minimum
of 25 3. i think the grant standard
and the statute don't need to parallel
anything further representative edwards
uh
yes sir i don't think i was really clear
on my example what i was trying to do is
to
pick the scenario where the town may
already exceed the federal standard but
it's still really
poor bandwidth and our standard of
at a gig is higher and so the
municipality is in an in between state
between the federal standard and our
standard
i'm just i'm just curious if we know
whether or not
um at that point the federal program
is even applicable and the state is
subsidizing the whole of the investment
and not
matching but replacing i
i hear the question uh now uh
representative thank you for clarifying
uh
um that would be a served community
and uh and and the residents of that
uh community that had a 25 megabytes
down
and three megabyte up service
that would be a served uh
household or business
thank you all right i think senator
bradley is waiting to give
some further answers to some earlier
questions
senator bradley uh yes
i think representative ober had a
question
um i'm also trying to
testify on another bill in uh another
house committee so
i was going back and forth and i didn't
hear a question oh jeb i'm sorry i asked
said since i you're i would like to say
your executive assistant
sent me senator khan's amendment this
morning after we had already started our
hearing at 10 o'clock and i appreciated
that
i asked senator khan since you had a
copy of my
amendment already if he had already
taken the steps to go to ols and say can
we have a combined amendment with this
because we're going to move this morning
and we only have
we don't have two hearings posted and he
said no
my second question was was there another
bill in the senate that his amendment
could be attached to to modify this and
he didn't know and since i've been since
i asked that i've been sitting here
wondering to myself
if that's a piece we could add to the
department of energy
during the committee of conference on
the budget or if gary daniels could add
that now
so i was trying to find a way to
incorporate that we could still go ahead
your thoughts yeah so representative
ober
if you want us to um take action
in another setting whether it's hb2 or
another bill
on the amendment that senator khan and i
are sponsoring together
we can accommodate that if that makes
your life easier
we'll get it done i appreciate
that senator bradley because we do not
have
another session scheduled in house
finance after this so i was trying to
make that work
i apologize i honestly it's my fault i
had forgotten about this amendment
apologies in particular
to senator khan because i should have
known better but
um we'll we'll fix it and again i'm
sorry i
didn't have it earlier to you no problem
thank you for working with us yep
thank you both senator nordgren for a
question
senator norgren is right here um thank
you
nordgren um this is just a process
question it appears that we have
issues in divisions one and two
with bills that we're hearing today that
normally would have gone back to the
division so they could work
on them further division three is doing
that
this afternoon at one o'clock with the
bills we have
i just think we're trying to do too much
in one day
and finish up things when maybe we need
more time
and let the divisions carry on their
usual work
that's just my comment thank you thank
you and i'm
not sure whether we will have that
division
session this afternoon or not i don't
think that decision has been made
all right uh do we have uh andrea do we
have further people waiting to testify
yes we do we have um
chris norwood so i will try to bring him
in right now
thank you and i see hands up
still if if you're finished with your
questions if you'd lower them
good morning good morning thank you mr
chair my name is chris norwood
and i'm speaking today on behalf of the
new hampshire association of realtors
i'm their volunteer public policy chair
the committee has heard a lot of
technical questions today
relative to speeds as well as um
how to make amendments work to which i
can say i am not familiar with those
details i'm here
testifying in support of the need of
senate bill 85
establishing matching funds for local
municipalities
years ago before the pandemic i can tell
you that i connected with realtors
throughout the state and i
personally was naive about the number of
homes in our state that do not have
access to reliable internet
and that was all like i said pre-covered
access to fast reliable service is no
longer an added benefit to a home but
much as a necessity senator bradley
talked about online schooling
telemedicine and work from home
requirements
clearly everything is very very
important to home buyers today
it's not an exaggeration that high-speed
broadband
is now becoming as essential as water
electricity and other things that we
consider
required utilities to make a home
operate
and i believe that fast reliable
internet really helps our communities
prosper
there was a department of commerce study
that concluded high-speed internet
access increased property values six
percent
uh this obviously helps our local
municipals municipalities
achieve a higher tax base as well
and it's not just on the residential
side i personally work on the commercial
side of the industry
and i can tell you that it's one of the
first questions that
users of space ask me and now in
pandemic
it's not just the office users it's also
warehouse
distribution contractors these
businesses
require fast and reliable
internet and that's why i ask you to
join
the new hampshire association of
realtors in supporting
sb thank you very much and i'll
entertain any questions
thank you mr norwood any questions from
the committee
i don't see any thank you for your
testimony
thank you mr chair and andrea who do we
have next
we have maura weston which i will bring
in now
more off you could please a mute yes
good morning can you
hear me now yes mr president thank you
very much
good morning for the record my name is
mara weston
i appreciate the opportunity to speak
with you today
i'm testifying on behalf of the new
england cable and telecommunications
association
necta our members including atlantic
broadband
charter and comcast are new hampshire's
leading broadband providers with over
000 customers in more than 184
communities
our members are proud to be new
hampshire's first providers to offer
gigabit speeds throughout their networks
we are here today to testify in support
of senate bill 85.
new hampshire's challenges relative to
broadband are not
unique to rural states however
with the forthcoming influx of federal
dollars
that we see on the horizon we believe
that new hampshire is well positioned
to help close the connectivity gap and
this
piece of legislation we believe to be
critical
in that process nectar endorses
public-private partnerships
that are technology and provider neutral
to solve the challenge of how best to
bring broadband
to parts of the state that currently
lack access
and that is the approach that this bill
takes
furthermore senate bill 85 includes key
safeguards to ensure that public
dollars are invested in areas where they
are truly
needed to connect unserved populations
in an efficient sustainable and
the programs envisioned by senate bill
85 will attract we believe
a broad range of internet service
providers capable of building
sustainable
high-speed networks in the most
cost-efficient manner
using public-private partnerships will
leverage private sector dollars
and expertise to get the most out of
available
state or federal monies with a finite
amount
of funds available to solve the
remaining connectivity gaps
in new hampshire senate bill 85
correctly allocates dollars to projects
that do not have alternative funding
available
or would not be completed without this
program's assistance
necta understands the urgent need to
serve currently unserved areas in new
hampshire
and we believe that this is the best
pathway forward to achieve this goal
and we stand ready to partner with the
state and municipalities in new
hampshire to do so
with that i'm happy to answer questions
um
and i wanted to just touch on
senator edwards question that he
asked senator
representative edwards rather
i would stress that that this is an
opportunity to serve
unserved areas and so a higher
standard of up to a gigabit
would not preclude any municipality or
uh communications district or county
from pursuing
participation in this program um
but those dollars allocated
through this uh program would
remain focused on unserved areas
in whatever the municipality saw to be
the best
and i'm happy to answer any of the
questions thank you miss weston
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
andrea how many people do we have that
want to speak to us
we have john pascarelli who had
previously expressed interest
to speak so i can bring him in any after
him
i do not see any other hands raised at
this time but i will ask
that anyone who does want to speak that
they raise their hand at this time
all right and i would also ask that if
if we've heard
some of the same testimony that's
somewhat uh repetitious i'd ask if any
of them
have anything new to add that they would
come on but if it's
if it's more or less to say the same
thing then uh
just to say they support the bill would
be fine thank you
mr pascarelli welcome back
hello senators how are we doing today
well we're also mostly representatives
here
okay mostly representatives um
after listening to all of you folks's
you know in-depth conversation
i came to a few conclusions one
conclusion is that you came up with a
federal standard
you know of 25 down and three up
um just so that you folks have some
valuable information
you know to toss around this is a dsl
line that i'm currently on
which is a three megabyte dsl
that i'm trying to operate you know
the music industry and it's almost
virtually impossible
and i guess my biggest question is
are some of you representatives gonna
try to introduce a bill
that's gonna allow some of this funding
to go above your federal standard
because
i think the federal standard is what i'm
on
which you folks have already talked
about is
way way too low i mean if you're gonna
be reaching out into these rural areas
like i am out here in swansea
you know and i'm on a old-fashioned
analog
converted digital line to be here on the
internet
you know that you know stan that federal
standard that you folks are talking
about
would be just ridiculous to serve the
customers in the state of new hampshire
and i've also been attending a lot of
the
zoom meetings with south region
southwest regional planning committee
i've been
voicing my voice you know with that with
the planning council
bring it to the forefront you know that
if you're talking about a copper wire
which would even
include a cable company copper wire has
its limitations of speeds
granted it's a choice
that's better than what i'm using
but we have fiber optic
networking out here in these telephone
poles
which is the severe superior
source of internet in my opinion
and i think that there should be some
some of you representatives that should
be pushing
you know to increase that
federal standard now i realize that
we're talking about the state of new
hampshire and we're talking about the
feds
but i mean i think it should be part of
you folks is process
that when they try to apply for some of
this funding
that like for example i'm on three
megabyte i don't want to be disqualified
for better internet because i already
got three megabytes i don't want to be
disqualified
because i got three megabytes i don't
think that'd be fair
so i think this should be some sort of
terminology
you know to put in there somewhere that
if people are going to be upgrading
their broadband they should be upgrading
and spending the money wisely to get the
best they possibly could get
and just to throw another piece in there
i've been working with consolidated you
know and me as just a plain
joe resident out here
on my little piece of land if i want to
get
this broadband service brought to my
home
the quote that i was quoted was five
thousand dollars it's gonna cost me five
thousand dollars
to get broadband at my home and you know
i think if you get a chance to speak
with some residents
folks aren't going to be able to afford
that not only that but
i'm in the town of swansea the town of
swansea
they can't afford it either so i mean i
think we're going to run into some
roadblocks but
i wanted a chance to support you guys's
bill i support it
i wanted a chance to reach out to
representatives like a large group like
this
and give you my feedback as a plain jane
resident out here in the field what i'm
experiencing
that's it i support the bill
thank you mr pascarelli i think we had
some testimony that
it would uh it would not be restricted
to that
that um federal standard that it would
likely
whatever the the area was requesting
would be supported i believe that was
the case but
whether we had to go further and to put
into uh
into uh another type of cable i'm not
sure whether that's in it or not but
we'll find out later as
as we go we still don't know all the
rules on the
money that's going to be available and
we're waiting and waiting
to find out so when we do find out if
it's needed to go to a higher standard
then i'm sure that there will be
legislation submitted but it won't be
able to
take effect right away thank you
seeing none thank you sir thank you
uh andrea is there anybody else that it
uh we have a lisa steadman
who is raise their hand if we can bring
hi thank you very much i'm lisa steadman
from troy new hampshire that's also in
the monadnock region
i'm serving on our broadband committee
there and we're in that camp of
that group of towns that have proposed
to form a private and public partnership
with consolidated communications
i think there's some feeling that we've
lost some opportunity
by moving too fast that perhaps this
grant can't benefit
us because we already have a partnership
proposed with consolidated in in our
partnership we're going to have a
20-year
municipal bond they're going to pay for
the bond so it's not really a cost to
our town
but the folks who do sign up for the
consolidated service will pay a user fee
of 9.50 per month until the bond is paid
off
so it's not exactly free to the people
who want to take advantage of the
high-speed internet that's coming to our
town
i think that the committee and others
are interested in knowing whether this
matching grant could help to benefit our
town
by reducing the end user fee that's
being
brought on by consolidated
communications and we're just not clear
about whether the grant funds can be
thank you ma'am are there any questions
on miss stedman's testimony
seeing none thank you for your testimony
andrew is anyone further on this bill we
do have a tom bascom
uh thank you um so i'm
i'm in greenfield uh where we also like
troy
have a project that has been approved
and we're concerned about the timing uh
whether or not our project could qualify
for this funding the uh amendment that
senator bradley and senator khan are
proposing is is very important to us
that would that would certainly make a
big difference to
our cost structure because if we can get
matching funds
then we should be able to reduce the
bond amount
by you know half
which would make a significant
difference to the
subscribers in town we're also concerned
about the overall timing and the
rulemaking and
you know how long this is going to take
to get a decision
from osi or whoever ends up
putting together that process so we
would encourage
uh the committee to establish
aggressive timelines and to pass senator
bradley and senator khan's
amendment so that the towns may fully
participate
in in this process thank you mr baskin
are there any questions on mr baskin's
testimony
thank you for your testimony
andrea do we have anyone else i see no
others wishing to speak
thank you all right if there's no one
else wishing to speak i'll
end the public hearing on house bill 85
and i'd like to go into an executive
session on house bill 85
and this subject matter was before
division one
representative ober do you wish to make
a motion uh mr chairman could i ask mr
hoffman to present the amendment we have
on sb 85 and then
representative emerick will be moving
ought to pass
as amended very good
mr hoffman can you show that amendment
and
let's let's show us get the number of it
so that clerk can get the number of the
uh amendment first i can't move it out
all right here it is 1328 thank you now
move it up
thanks so mr chairman as
senator bradley said he and i were
concerned
we both support the bill the bill takes
effect july 1st this does not change
that
but on july 1st the office of strategic
initiatives which is named in the bill
would cease to exist and the department
of energy would take over
so this amendment has contingency
language
should the budget be vetoed
the office of strategic initiatives
remains in this bill
should the budget pass the duties of the
office of strategic initiatives
will pass to the department of of energy
so that there is no lapse in our ability
to move forward with these important
grants
senator bradley spoke to this bill this
amendment he and i worked on it together
before it was drafted
we felt we needed the contingency work
and i thank senator bradley for working
on the other amendment that he and mr
khan
will pass on another bill so
representative emerick is recognized for
a motion
a lot to pass with this amendment
which is 1328 h so i moved
all right a motion by representative
emmerich seconded by
representative griffin to have ought to
pass as
amended for senate bill 85
normally we adopt the amendment before
we go to or not to pass as amended
so i would move the amendment all right
let's
vote first on the amendment clerk will
call a roll on the amendment
1328. who is the uh i second that
joe represent emmerich and
all right representative ober yes
yes representative uh renzullo
representative the burris yeah
representative petrie golcias
representative emrick yes representative
earth
yes representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes off of mute still yes
representative bean representative lynn
yes representative walner
yes representative
yes representative bucco
yes representative uh
representative hatch representative
rogers
yes representative waltz
yes presenter heath
representative weiler yes mr chairman of
voters 21-0
in favor and the amendment is adopted we
now go back to the amend
to the motion by representative emmerich
seconded by representative griffin
for ought to pass as amended by house
all right and this was american over
okay representative ober
yes there was an umbrella
yes representative
renzolo yes president
yes represent petri volcas
representative emerick
yes representative earth yes
representative griffin yeah edwards
yes representative bean
representative lynn yes representative
walner
yes representative norgren yes
president puko representative uh
grassy yes
representative hatch representative
rogers
yes representative walsh
yes representative heath yes
representative murray yes rosanna weiler
yes mr chairman the voters 21-0 in favor
of the amendment of the
bill mr chairman since this bill has no
money can it go on consent
i was just about to say that all right
we have a
the motion is ought to pass as amended
has been adopted
um since it's unanimous we will put this
could i ask mr hoffman to show
okay mr hoffman did you copy that
amendment 2021 as requested which which
bill was that for
that's on 77 i believe mr hoffman walked
hard copies up to the finance room and
you have a cop a hard copy in front of
you
it's 13 the number is 1363 that we have
in front of us
yes i i can share that yes
i believe andrea i think i emailed that
to you
as well so either one of us can
all right so if the committee's ready
we'll come out of recess
on senate bill 77 by presenting the
amendment
that needed some work and mr hoffman
will
yes this uh amends the bill
by adding a section at the end pushing
the effective
date down to section three so it
retains the text of senate bill 77 as it
came to you
but adds this paragraph in
existing statute there is a paragraph
uh roman numeral 11 so that's why it
looks like it's skipping over but it's
okay everyone have a chance to look at
this i believe it's done what we
requested
is there a motion as we've come out of
recess
on the exact session on senate bill 77
let me make that clear
we're now out of recess on senate bill
77 we're back to a
um exec session on senator bill 77 we
have before us amendment 1
3 6-3 is there a motion
representative griffin moves that we
adopt
amendment 1363 is there a second
second by representative taberge is
there any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
on amendment 1363 on amendment 77.
senate bill 77 representative
yes oh representative
yes representative ranzulo
yes representative
yes representative petry votes yes
representative emerick yes
earth yes representative griffin
yes representative bean
representative lynn yes
representative nordgren yes
arizona yes
representative grassy yes
president hatch representative rogers
yes representative walsh yes
representative heath yes representative
murray
yes representative weiler yes
mr chairman of voters 21-0 to adopt the
amendment
all right we've adopted amendment 1363.
i'll now entertain a motion to adopt
senate bill 77 as amended by
senate by house by amendment 1363.
representatives second by representative
griffin
ought to pass as amended senate bill 77
ought to pass as amended by
all right this is senate bill 77
[Music]
yes representative uh renzolo
yes representative yes
president peter gotchas representative
emrick
yes representative era yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
representative lynn yes
i see that yes there we go thank you
president woodbring yes
president grassy yes
representative rogers yes thank you
rosanna walsh yes
presenter heath yes representative
murray
yes and representative weiler
yes mr chairman the vote is 21-0
in favor of the bill okay we have
adopted senate bill
77 as amended since there's money in it
chairman yes go ahead representative
over
thank you um the actual house rule is if
the money is
less than ten thousand dollars it can
still be on the consent calendar
[Music]
is this less than ten thousand yep okay
i guess we can put it on consent thank
you
all right next on our schedule is the
senate bill 98 and we'll open the public
hearing on senate bill 98
and we have somebody here to testify
likely the prime sponsor we do
it looks like we have senator whitley
who i'll bring in now
good afternoon good morning welcome to
house finance thank you very much thank
you mr chair and
good morning almost good afternoon to
members of the committee for the record
my name is becky whitley and i'm honored
to serve
new hampshire senate district 15 which
includes the wonderful communities of
concord penacook henniker hopkinton and
warner
i'm honored today to bring forth sb 98
relative to the snap incentive program
this bill has enjoyed
broad support in the senate with
unanimous votes out of committees
and in the full senate so just very
simply the bill
creates a snap incentive program in
state statute
and this type of program allows snap
shoppers
to purchase additional fruits and
vegetables by matching their purchases
of
fresh fresh produce snap incentives are
very popular they lead to really a
triple win for new hampshire
including more money flowing into the
local economy
health benefits for our most vulnerable
populations
and new opportunities for our local
farmers there are a variety of
stakeholders today who can speak further
to the details of the program but snap
incentives are actually
already active at dozens of farmers
markets
and 18 grocery stores throughout new
hampshire
via the granite state market match and
double up food box programs
but these are privately funded programs
sb 98 was introduced to show just a
modest
state investment and create
infrastructure within state government
very limited infrastructure to be able
to draw down
additional federal dollars to broaden
access
to the program for more snap recipients
so i'm happy to take
any questions but i will defer the more
technical questions
to the folks behind me who can speak to
the federal programs
and the existing programs we have in new
hampshire thank you mr chair
i thank you representative excuse me
thank you senator whitley
any questions from the committee for the
senator
who do we have next
next we have a brendan cornwall which
hello good morning welcome to uh
senate finance okay correction house
finance
thank you looking at the senate bill and
getting confused
uh thank you for letting me speak today
i'm brendan cornwell from the new
hampshire food bank
and i am the new hampshire nutrition
incentive network coordinator
we have two incentive programs in the
state of new hampshire granite state
market match and double up food box
these incentive programs offer snap
customers the opportunity to double
their snap dollars on fruits and
vegetables at participating locally
owned independent retailers farmers
markets
farm stands and csas when a snap shopper
uses their card
at one of these participating locations
to for example
purchase a melon that cost two dollars
the shopper is only charged one and the
other one dollar is covered by the
incentive program
this gives the snap customer the ability
to expand on benefits they are given to
purchase healthy food
the usda requires a federal a
non-federal
cash match as part of the gush
schumacher nutrition incentive program
grant
a permanent mandatory funded program of
the farm bill
the funds asked for in sb 98 only
account for 25
of our required match however when we
are talking about our match that is only
a fraction of the influx
of federal funds these programs bring
and keep in the state of new hampshire
sb 98 accounts for a total of 3 percent
of the total infusion of funds
when you look at the full picture the
inrush of funds to new hampshire
is ten million one hundred and ninety
six thousand eight hundred and thirty
seven
that is the sum of everything all the
incentives match admin marketing and
federal snap dollars being spent
and kept in the granite state that is
the amount that these programs will help
infuse into the new hampshire economy
over the next two years
that 10 million 196 837 dollars is being
spent at locally owned
independent grocery stores and farmers
markets and co-ops
instead of big box and super stores
these independent stores are more
neighborhood focused they support their
local communities
and they pay their workers a living wage
produce from that 10
196 837 is spent on fruits and
vegetables grown by new hampshire
farmers
instead of grown by farmers from
california or mexico
it enables new hampshire farmers to hire
additional workers upgrade equipment and
expand their operations
these incentive programs are good for
new hampshire they take federal money
and keep it in the state
and help new hampshire's economy grow
please support sb 98 and keep these
funds in new hampshire
thank you thank you mr cornwell are
there any questions from the committee
seeing none do we have anybody else
yes we do we have an eileen loponis
still good morning thank you very much
division three for hearing from us
my name is eileen loponis i'm the
executive director of new hampshire food
bank and with me
and we are both fully vaccinated
my name is elise polster i'm the
registered dietitian and nutrition
programs manager here at the people
we have grouping i get to oversee the
staff incentive program
and work closely with brendan cornwall
we want to give you a visual of the
farmers markets that our snap incentives
are purchased at we are very
hopeful that you participate in this and
support this program with us
um we have been the fiscal agent for
granite state market match for over 10
years
and most recently the fiscal agent for
double up food bucks
so we hold two of the incentive programs
in the state
we're very excited because this is a
natural extension of our programming
our nutrition programming is really
geared at
bringing more nutritious foods to our
new hampshire food insecure
it helpfully hopefully positively impact
their health and lower our overall
health care costs in the state
but this program is part of our snap
outreach we are one of the only snap
outreach programs in the state
that's where we help folks who want to
sign up for snap incentives otherwise
formally known as food stamps we also
run a cooking matters program
that's nutrition education for families
individuals and children
where they learn how to cook on a budget
unit pricing
stretch their dollar and really get more
from what they purchase at the grocery
store
this is an example behind us of what
they could get if they were able to
purchase the program
purchase the incentive program how much
more they could purchase in fruits and
vegetables
we also recently started a program that
also benefits new hampshire farmers new
hampshire feeding new hampshire
where we have a certain amount of money
that we privately raise to give to our
over 400 partner agencies throughout the
state
where they are able to purchase directly
from our local farmers and have that
local produce in their
pantries and soup kitchens we are doing
this
as we said to extend our nutrition
programming to helpfully
hopefully positively impact the health
of our
most vulnerable in our state are food
insecure
um we are trying to make this as
painless to the state as possible
we do all the reporting we are just the
fiscal agent and they are merely a pass
through
the only thing that dhs would have to do
is write the rsa for us
rfa myself apologies um we are
participating with 50 farmers markets
throughout the state right now
and 18 retail stores which brendon
outlines you are independent and locally
focused
and last year over 8 000 families
participated
in this program it is very popular and
very
um helpful to our food insecure to have
access to this nutritious food
um with that i'd like to take any uh
questions
all right thank you any questions from
seeing none um are there any other
people waiting to testify
and about how many do we have uh we have
two
signed up and we have two hands raised
that are not on the list
okay let's uh hope we we don't hear a
lot of more repetitious we know that
this is an important program
and uh let's see who we have next
sure next we have rebecca wachowski and
good morning welcome to finance
committee good morning
my name is rebecca voikovsky and i'm
here today on behalf of new futures
to state our strong support of sb98 and
i promise i will not be repetitious i
just want to make
two points i'm number one new future is
a non-profit nonpartisan advocacy
organization that advocates to improve
the health and wellness of all new
hampshire's residents
especially our young children we stand
in strong support of senate bill 988
because we know research has shown that
the impact of certain adversity
including poverty and early childhood
negatively impacts lifelong health
outcomes
and increased state costs we have heard
today that snap incentive programs
provide opportunity for healthy foods
for our
most at risk families and we know that
access to these foods combats the
negative health
and life impacts of poverty and reduces
lifelong costs to the state snap
incentive programs also support a
healthy triple bottom line as you heard
senator whitley
explained in the beginning and this is
by increasing access to healthy foods
for families
increasing business for farmers and
providing a boost to our local economy
and you heard brendan
speak about that 10 million dollar
number so in sum we want to say that the
positive impacts of these programs are
so essential to
our families in new hampshire and even
more critical given the challenges coven
19 has placed
on families facing food and security for
these reasons new futures urges the
committee to vote senate bill 1998 ought
to pass
and i'm happy to answer any questions if
there are any thank you ma'am any
questions from the committee
and who do we have next next next we
have uh elizabeth alpern
good afternoon welcome to finance
committee hello thank you
thanks so much thanks for having me
my name is liz alpern and i wanted to
share that i'm part
i was part of launching double up food
box in new hampshire in 2017.
and back in 2017 we worked very closely
with
associated grocers of new england based
in pembroke to
identify stores that would be a good fit
for the program
we actually started with four stores in
this program and as you've heard
we now have grown to 18 participating
retailers in nine
counties throughout the state of new
hampshire
and in particular i wanted to share that
our local retailers really do benefit
from participating in this program and
we currently have more
stores that want to participate in this
program
than we can possibly on board given the
budget
and so our hope is to expand the reach
of this program
uh beyond those 18 stores
and i wanted to just offer one example
um we work with a berlin marketplace
in berlin new hampshire berlin was
berlin marketplace was one of the
original stores to join
the program in 2017 the pilot program
this is the only fully operational
grocery store in berlin
it serves a really wide array of
community members and
the program has continued to grow in
that store and in that community over
time it attracts new customers to the
store
and it also helps retain existing
customers so they are shopping locally
in berlin
and not just going down the street to
walmart
and in particular what touches me so
much about working at a store like
berlin marketplace is that the manager's
there
and the cashiers there they know the
shoppers they know the farmers who sell
them the summer squash the mushrooms the
herbs
during the grows growing season and this
is an independently owned store that has
benefited the community for decades and
programs like double up food bugs help
these stores continue to
thrive in those local communities so i'm
more than happy to answer any questions
about the retail aspect of the program
and how
it benefits all of our local business
owners
thank you thank you ma'am any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
who do we have next that completed our
list of
signed up testimony however we have two
other hands raised so alan reitz would
good afternoon mr reece welcome to the
finance committee
good afternoon and and thank you for
this opportunity i'm alan reeds with the
hanover co-op food stores
i've worked at this cooperative since
1995. i'm also a plainfield resident
um and i thank you again for this
opportunity to speak mr chair
um our food co-op is in strong support
of sb 98
as lizel pern had pointed out
we are one of the retailers one of those
that has grown into the program
and we happen to be one of the larger
retailers in the state
when we became part of it we saw
immediate impact and i'm not talking
about to our bottom line specifically
i'm talking about to the number of sign
ups
for this program that surprised even us
a store that has been selling groceries
in new hampshire since 1936.
so you know since the time we joined the
program snap recipients shopping here
purchased over a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in fresh produce
and that allowed us to to really serve
some of the most
vulnerable in our communities and really
double their
double their buying power for fruits and
vegetables using those snap funds so
just to get right to the point families
with limited income
they know the value that fresh produce
provides
we've seen them jump at the chance to
eat nutritiously
and buy from local farmers so this is
about helping local people with
resources that are close to home
and i i urge your support and thank you
because
we want to double up state and federal
dollars and
spread the health i'm happy to answer
any questions i can
from the retailer's perspective thank
you mr reece any questions from the
committee members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for the opportunity
and who do we have next we have a
hello uh chairman and the committee and
thank you for allowing me to speak my
name is tiffany dodier and i'm a
registered dietitian
speaking on behalf of the new hampshire
public health association which is a
statewide membership
organization composed of health care and
public health professionals
for the last 25 years we've advocated
for policies that improve the health of
new hampshire's people
so today i wanted to submit testimony on
behalf of our members and partners to
state our strong support
of sb 98 relative to the snap incentive
program
and um what i really wanted to foot stop
to
the committee is that this is an
evidence-based best practices
program that is actually shown in
studies to increase servings of fruits
and vegetables by snap participants
by as much as five servings per day and
so what of course that equals out to
is more health and more prosperity and
better economics for the state so for
sb-98
it's not just about improving access to
food for the hungry but it's also about
improving access to healthy foods
for those that are suffering from lower
diet quality meaning the foods that we
eat that nourish our bodies
in the granite state that can impact not
only their health but their productivity
and their prosperity in new hampshire's
economy
so with that i'll take any questions
about the health benefits and and
the research behind the actual snap
incentive program
thank you ma'am many questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
all right uh
andrea any further people waiting to
testify
we have no other hands raised at this
time okay
seeing no one else to testify i will
close the hearing
on senate bill 98 and
move into the executive session on this
bill
mr chair i believe uh representative
umberger has a question
okay representative burgess sorry did
you want question before i close the
hearing
uh yes i think so um
if i understood this bill this is a
one-time
the uh these
finance or the fiscal note just shows it
for 2022 and not for 2023
that's that's correct and i i was
um i was concerned that if we are going
that it would appear to me that it
should be
for more than one year because it is not
a um
it's not it didn't appear to be a
one-year program it seemed to me as i
was listening to the testimony
that this is something that should occur
more than one year and i guess my other
question would be
do we know if the senate is planning to
put this
or are we just going to
um allocate this money
and hope for the best all right let's
let's see if we have anybody from the
senate that can answer this question
anybody in the senate that's still
listening
any of the food bank people that might
know the answer
so i do have eileen who we could let's
i call her by your first name because
it actually appears on the fiscal note
for 150
000 in fiscal 22 but is broken down in
expenditures
over fiscal 22 and fiscal 23 of 75
000 each and we would be more than happy
to come back every year and ask for it
in each biennium budget
if you would support it thank you
okay does that answer your question yes
i'm sorry i did not go down to the
fiscal note i
i apologize i was uh
thank you very much eileen no problem
all right uh representative edwards do
you have a question for
i don't i was wondering when we were
going to get to the
exact session on this because i have an
amendment and a lot of research that
i've done that
i'm just looking for the appropriate
time to share with the committee
okay if there's uh no further questions
in the public hearing section we'll
close that again
and we'll go to the exact session
representative edwards representative
nordgren did you have a question
in well well i guess i'm just confused
because the calendar lists
division three meeting at one o'clock on
this bill and our other bill so i just
wanted a clarification we're going to
find out now whether representative
edwards
so there was some thought he may cancel
it
well the division members haven't heard
that neither is the public
representative edwards is recognized
thank you mr chair
um when i first got this bill uh i began
to research it by contacting
sponsors and co-sponsors and
i went into it initially with a couple
of
thoughts about it one is that
when you look at the underlying federal
program the gus schumacher program
on their website they state that
the federal government is running a
pilot program on this
through october excuse me through
fiscal year 23 which means that october
2023 if their website is correct the
program will expire so i thought it
would be appropriate for us to have
a suspense state included so that if the
program
expired and there no longer was any
federal money then
the state component of this would would
uh
automatically sunset um from
uh i i then subsequently had a long
conversation with uh
miss chris santanella of dhhs and miss
maureen burke
also of dhhs and miss burke
who follows us pretty closely
assures me that although the
program at the federal level is
scheduled to sunset
at the end of fy23
she believes that the administration has
indicated that they're going to continue
the program
past that and so
so if that's the case then
my interest in the sunset dissipates a
bit
the other part of this was i thought
that since there was a
grant program there that that we we
should ask the department
to go ahead and apply for a federal
match
so that the state's share was reduced in
half
and and again both ms antonella and ms
burke
assured me that the grants
are being applied for and they're being
applied for by our two
private uh charitable organizations in
the state that have been running this
program for a while
so so my interest in that is sloughed
off
so um so although i had ols
create an amendment to this um
i i'm not seeing a compelling need
to complicate uh the legislative process
with um a big debate on it
because i i i don't know that either of
the reasons for the amendment
are as compelling as i thought they were
initially
so i i don't see a need to to
debate the amendment and because we've
had
so much testimony in today's finance
committee
from people who were scheduled to come
in at one o'clock to division three
i i would be fine accepting
today's testimony to be
adequate to our purposes those purposes
are furthered
with the knowledge that senator aaron
hennessey
has stated that if uh
if we were to retain this bill uh
she is at a point in the budgetary
process
where she can take care of it and make
sure it gets into the budget
and so um so because
um the senate is uh looks to be
committed to
to funding this um and because
uh my amendment i think is largely moot
i i would i would i would ask the
committee to consider
um that we we go ahead and trust
senator hennessey to take care of the
funding for us on the senate
side of this in that uh when we get an
opportunity that we vote to retain
thank you representative edwards any
further comments from the committee
i guess i'll entertain a motion to
retain
senate bill 98 on the promise that it
will likely be funded in the budget i
move sir that we retain senate bill 98
on the promise that the senate is going
to fund this
second motion by representative edwards
seconded by representative irf
that the bill be retained is there any
further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on retain
for senate bill 98. right this bill is
to retain
senate bill 98 retain the motion is
retained senate bill 98
representative renzulo yes
burrish yeah representative peter of
octs
representative emerick yes
representative erf
yes representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean representative lynn
now
nordgren no
representative uh grassy
no president hatch
no
no representative murray
no representative wyler
yes mr chairman the vote is 11-9
in favor of retention okay
motion to retain is adopted this does
not need to go in the calendar except
to list it as being retained
mr church the last bill we
requested representative edwards uh just
just
because it seems like an appropriate
spot here
uh i i i think because of this
uh i'll end up canceling today's meeting
i'll i'll go ahead and open it
at one o'clock because it's on the
calendar but then
i'll close it shortly thereafter
thank you thank you for that
announcement all right
next on our schedule is senate bill 152
relative to affordable housing programs
i'll open the public hearing on senate
bill 152
and we have we have the
sponsor to speak to it
senator gray oh he just unmuted
good morning mr chair this is shannon
gerard assistant to
senator gray he is in election law right
now
chairing his committee so i will be
simply introducing senate bill 152
thank you please go ahead good morning
mr chair and members of the committee
my name is shannon gerrard assistant to
senator james gray
who represents senate district six and
is chairing the election law at this
time and currently unavailable
unable to attend the senator asked if i
could simply introduce
act relative to affordable housing
program funding and defer any questions
to him
in regards to this bill i would like to
mention though mr chair that the
department of health and human services
should also be here to testify
and answer any questions
thank you ma'am any questions any
questions from the committee
seeing none we'll move on to the next
person mr chair it does look like
uh senator gray is with us but maybe
under another name so i will
good good afternoon senator good
afternoon
shannon did a wonderful job uh
introducing the bill
since its uh introduction health and
human services
has uh testimony that they will provide
about the need for the bill
and i will defer to them uh but again
i'd like to thank shannon
uh for for doing that i just got uh
out of executive session and uh i was
just
able to catch her uh her full speech
very good are you finished with that
other session are you going right back
to it
no i'm uh finished with that and
i have a break for you know 35 minutes
till my next one
very good any questions i see
thank you mr chair and and uh senator
great
thank you for talking to me uh last week
or the week before about this bill
and i understand uh your your
relationship
to it and how how you're working with
the governor's office and the department
i just happened to re-read it again and
for the first time
it popped out at me that uh with this
uh our this in the rsa
the commissioner could potentially
uh extend the timeline for repayments
indefinitely without any limitation to
how far
that they could be extended to the
effect
of of canceling the repayment altogether
do you do you think that was the intent
of this legislation or do you
do or do you disagree with me that that
may be the effect
of this legislation the original wording
of that did come from the governor's
office
but when health and human services
testifies
they will tell you that the both
sections of the bill
are not needed and will give you some
indication of where they're already
covered
so although your question is interesting
i think it'll be moved by the time
you get to acting on the bill my
favorite word today thank you
senator thank you senator i hear you say
that uh
hhs has the funds for this five million
dollars a year
they will testify as to the need for the
bill
and i believe they will be telling you
that both sections are already covered
appreciate it thank you anything further
from the committee
all right then andrea moving on to the
next we have chris sensing yellow i'll
bring them in now
good afternoon this is chris santaniello
can you hear me
yes i can thank you okay sometimes it
goes back and forth um i am here from
the department of health and human
services and i'm here to talk about
sections one and sections two in
senate bill 152 um section one
relates to the 1915 i
state plan amendment um to the medicaid
program for supportive services to
assist individuals and families
to obtain and maintain their housing
this
is actually already mandated by house
bill
4 in 2019 and the department is
actually actively working with the
center for medicare and medicaid
um on moving this state plan amendment
forward we actually
um submitted a draft
last month to cms
we received some initial feedback are
making those modifications
um and we actually anticipate um
posting the um plan the draft um state
plan amendment
by the end of this month so that we can
submit it to cms
um for approval um and then we'll be
able to provide that service so we're
already
well underway in making this happen um
so that piece really isn't necessary as
part of
thank you very much so is are you saying
the the bill is unnecessary
the section one and then for section two
that is no longer necessary because
actually
um the department um
through um through its omnibus
um bill in section 11 actually asked to
have this
fund removed um because the way
and and we and creating a housing
stability fund
which we have um included in our current
um budget um
the issue with the existing homeless
access revolving loan fund is it's very
specific to um
first month's rent security deposit are
people who are literally
homeless and and the problem is
that it doesn't allow for other um forms
of assistance security deposit
um first month rent for people who are
unstably housed
or people who um a lot of people there's
this term called
double up and that's when someone may be
living with family or
living with people couch surfing and all
of that and they're not considered
technically homeless um but yet we can't
assist those
individuals in the current structure and
so
um also the way the current
homeless um housing access revolving
loan fund
is funded it doesn't allow for any
administrative expenses
for the partner agencies and so
in the last biennium we actually added
a million dollars in the um
for the eviction prevention funds and
that helps people who are homeless but
it also assists us
to support people before they become
homeless to remain in their housing
because we know that that's
what our ultimate goal is um and it's
much more comprehensive and so
um because we have that fund um this
is not really necessary at this moment
in time
thank you so the results if we make this
building expedient there's no change in
your program
correct thank you any further
uh questions from the committee
seeing none who do we have next thank
you very much miss santander hello
mr derosa welcome to the house finance
committee
thank you good afternoon mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is tom derosa and i serve as the
communications and engagement manager of
housing action new hampshire
we are a statewide coalition of 80
organizations united around affordable
housing policy
and ending homelessness in new hampshire
we're in support of sb 152
um given what the department just
testified and what they just said i
just want to say we're glad that senator
great to be interested in this
and we look forward to um watching the
waiver come through
thank you sir thank you any questions
for mr derosa
good afternoon members of the community
um i actually do not need to testify
um but thank you though for for calling
on me
well thank you very much thank you for
attending
who is next we do not have anyone else
with their hand raised and that
completed our list
okay that completes our list i will
close the hearing a public hearing on
on uh senate bill 152
and i will move to an exec session on
senate bill 152.
is there anybody in the committee wishes
to discuss it
representative edwards uh i
i'm i'm happy with the discussion i just
thought uh i'd
uh make the motion that we itlsb
152 based on uh the department's
testimony
representative edwards moves in
expedient to legislate is there a second
second from representative tuberge
further discussion back to
representative edwards
or did you lower your hand i just
lowered my hand i
i think the department's testimony said
it all
thank you very much all right
the emotion before us is inexpedient to
legislate
seeing no further discussion the clerk
will call the role on the motion of
inexpensive legislate
for senate bill 152.
okay this is an expedient
i'd like to be perfect
you're just better representing red
zoolo
representative petry vocias
representative emerick
yes representative erf
yes leonard griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean yes representative
yes
representative walner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative bucco yes
representative uh grassy yes
president hatch representative rogers
yes representative
yes president of heath yes
president of murray yes representative
weiler
yes mr chairman a vote is 20 to
zero to itl this motion
senate bill 152 is in expedient to
legislate by your vote
all right let's review what we've done
with the bills
well it had it did have money in it
no i mean uh as an itl doesn't the whole
house have to vote on it and if so
shouldn't we just put it on the consent
calendar as an itl
well not when it has money in it it's
got enough it's got like 10 million
dollars in it so we can
we won't put it that way and i guess
we'll have to have it on the regular
calendar
thank you for the education okay
so to uh let me see
i don't have a note here i believe so
here's our actions for today
senate bill 77 was ought to pass
as amended senate bill 82
joe what what was the final action on
that
i've got the rest of them but for some
reason i don't have a note on that one
it was itl 82 82 was itl
all right that was inexpedient senate
bill 85
was ought to pass as amended
senate bill 98 was retained
and senate bill 152 was inexpedient to
legislate
i appreciate you all being here
representative weiler
yes sb 77
was otpa i i thought i said that
no i didn't hear it if you did i
apologize all right
yeah otpa on senate bill 77 and
we came to a little late because we had
to change the amendment
get it right so all right
very good um
i got an announcement later for for
on division three we have a uh a set up
to tour
this afternoon this secure psychiatric
unit
so if you're not already signed up
let me know right now uh senator
representative edwards announcement
and in talking with paula matas uh
they need to have like 48 hours so they
can do a background check they can't
just have
people show up representative irf was a
was a late addition who almost was told
no
on friday because he was too late so
i think we can set up a another tour
but uh the the the it's all the inn is
full for today
no no no more participants
so who is it set up for today you uh
representative erf and myself and then
you can set up a
another one at another date we had tried
last monday and
and we just had a lot of people from
division three
unable to do it monday and
we just should set up a second one if
people still want to go
all right so anybody in division three
get in touch with the division three
chairman senator
uh representative edwards uh if you want
to go but
the three of us will be going this
afternoon at three o'clock uh
representative uh weiler yes
um i really think
that um other folks should be
allowed to go on that tour
if you have never been to the uh
secure psychiatric place
i uh i think it's uh informative
and um it's something that
all of us i think on finance uh
certainly need to be
somebody extend an invitation to the
remainder of the the committee
i recognize that division three
you know looks at that more carefully
than the rest of us
but uh it certainly is an eye-opening
experience
thank you representative umberger i i
just went to division three because i
thought it wouldn't be difficult to add
a couple more people
but everyone that in the in the
committee is
hereby invited uh representative edwards
will
set up the appropriate thing and
realize that it has to be 48 hours in
advance and they probably want to look
at all your background investigation
which i'm sure is no problem
but let that be done yes you're smiling
because we both had top secret
clearances where they
dig into everything thank you all right
i appreciate your attendance and i will
entertain a motion to adjourn
motion by representative petrie seconded
by who seconded it represented
oh all right and since we have a motion
in a second we don't need to
uh do a roll call so we are adjourned